so British military action in Syria
could become a reality with more than 50
Labour MPs I just reported prepared to
support intervention it's thought
meanwhile Russia says it is stepping up
its airstrikes in the region Moscow has
been accused of running a fundamentally
flawed campaign in Syria with the United
States warning it risks making the
crisis they're much worse well I'm join
now by Anders Fogh Rasmussen the former
Secretary General of NATO and prime
minister of Denmark he's in Copenhagen
in a very good morning to you and thank
you very much indeed for joining us
first of all mr. Rasmussen I'd like your
overview on just how dangerous situation
is becoming between NATO and Russia
taking in its actions in Syria the
overflights of turkey but not just that
also the situation in the Baltics and
other areas obviously it is a very
dangerous situation taking into account
that Russia has violated Turkish
airspace on several occasions and that
is a violation of NATO air space so of
course it is potentially a risk of a
conflict and a risk of conflict as was
said in the old Cold War days a mistake
perhaps leading to that an accident some
some small incidents spiraling out of
control yeah well I do hope that
military to military contacts could
prevent such incidents from escalating
into a very dangerous situation turkey
and NATO have issued very clear warnings
that the Russians must stop this
intimidation of NATO allies but to
understand what Putin what russia wants
one first castor I suppose look at the
history of the expansion of NATO and
really has Putin been looking for this
kind of opportunity since NATO started
recruiting the former Warsaw Pact
countries back in the late 90s
well it's not an accurate description of
what was happening that we recruited
former communist States as new members
of NATO actually they decided themselves
to apply for membership they became
flourish in democracies and of course
they have an inherent right to decide
their alliance affiliation themselves
and actually they wanted to become
members of NATO and the European Union
and after fulfilling the necessary
criteria they were accepted as members
which is normal but does mr. Putin see
it that way and do you think as I say
that that has rankled ever since it
started happening whether they were our
store requested well the fact is that
Russia is actually the main beneficiary
of our enlargement policies because due
to the enlargement of NATO and the
European Union we have created a zone of
stability and prosperity in Central and
Eastern Europe and when you have a look
at trade figures and investment figures
you will see that Russia has benefited
greatly from that zone of stability and
prosperity and furthermore for centuries
Russia has seeked stability along its
western borders and that's exactly what
we have created and NATO does not
constitute a threat to Russia in any way
I mean I hear you loud and clear do you
think President Putin and others in
Russia see it that way no apparently
they see it quite differently we have
tried to reach out to Russia on several
occasions back in 1997 we allowed Russia
to establish a kind of embassy or
permanent representation in the middle
of NATO headquarters in Brussels in 2002
we establish something very special
namely a nato-russia Council to serve as
a forum for consultations and joint
decisions this is Russia's the only
country outside an 80 with whom we have
such of accountants so I think we have
done a lot to reach out to Russia and
include them in the euro-atlantic
security architecture so what is your
view I mean back to this specific I mean
clearly President Putin is probing for
weaknesses with those overflights in
particular NATO member Turkey and if
they don't stop or if they even increase
how should NATO respond but it's very
clear how Turkey would respond if
Turkish airspace is violated there's a
clear risk that the Turks will shoot
down such aircraft also if it's a
Russian aircraft and Turkey will of
course be backed by its NATO allies to
what extent well that depends on the
concrete situation it's a case by case a
decision but in general it's clear that
a violation of NATO air space could
constitute what we call an article 5
situation you will recall that the
famous article five states that we
consider an attack on one and attack on
all hmm I do and so therefore back to
that earlier point I made isn't there
than a danger of rapid escalation if the
Turks shoot down a Russian aircraft it's
pretty unlikely that the Russians
wouldn't respond then NATO gets involved
obviously that would be a very dangerous
escalation of the whole situation and
this is also reason why both Turkey and
NATO have issued clear warnings to the
Russians to seize
the intimidation of turkey and the
violations of Turkish airspace in
general the Russian military presence in
Syria is a dangerous escalation of the
whole situation and it complicates the
situation because it will it serves to
save asset sacrifice the moderate
opposition and fuel the recruitment of
Islamic state fighters russia says it's
only filling that vacuum that has been
left there for the last four years as
the Syrian situation has festered with
the benefit of hindsight say either
collectively or individually should NATO
members have got more involved there
earlier well the fact is that you cannot
save asset and at the same time fight
Islamic state because the majority of
nations and peoples in the Middle East
want to get rid of asset you can save
asset and stop the bloodshed in Syria
because it is the brutality of the Assad
regime that started the whole thing in
the first place back in 2011 so that's
why it's it's very hard to see the Assad
regime as part of a long-term
sustainable solution in Syria and just
finally mr. Rasmussen may I ask you as a
former prime minister of course of key
EU member Denmark your view now on the
UK's attempt to have some kind of
renegotiation in terms of its
relationship with the European Union
given what is going on much of the
problems sparked by the Syrian refugee
crisis people coming from there and many
other countries as well is the EU really
in a mood for a big renegotiation with
the United Kingdom to change its
relationship fundamentally well I I hope
that the outcome of this whole process
will be that the United King
stays as a member of the European Union
obviously after some necessary reforms
and in that river on that reform agenda
I don't think the UK is is alone other
EU countries might support such requests
for reforms of the European Union but
the European Union needs the United
Kingdom as a member so I hope an
arrangement can be found that will allow
the United Kingdom to stay as a member
of the European Union but there must be
elements of frustration building in
places like Denmark as well I mean
president Hollande of France voiced it
last week when he said in reaction to my
former guests there to a speech by the
UK bleeder Nigel Farage well if you if
you don't like me you then do leave well
at the end of the day of course it is
for the British people to decide what is
going to happen i express my view coming
from from denmark that we need the UK
approach to EU policies so it will it
would significantly weaken the european
union on the world stage if the UK were
to leave the European Union so I I
really do hope that negotiations will
lead to an outcome that can be accepted
by the British people as well as the
European Union unless fair Rasmussen
great to have your thoughts thank you
very much indeed for sparing the time to
talk to us